le nouveau smartphone de Google vient
d'arriver c'est le Google pixel 7a alors
il a été présenté il y a pas très
longtemps et ce pixel 7a il va être
intéressant pour pas mal de petites
choses notamment au niveau de la photo
au niveau de toutes les fonctionnalités
de Google parce que si vous le savez si
vous aimez Google et bien Google fait du
Google avec une puce maison qui est là
maintenant depuis le pixel 6 avec une
puce de sécurité également maison et
puis surtout le gros point fort de ce
smartphone c'est ça toujours été chez
Google et bien il est parti photos une
partie photo où on retrouve deux
capteurs là où plein de Mac vous mettent
trois capteurs dans le haut du milieu de
gamme plutôt dans le dans le haut de
gamme bon c'est pas trop comment le
positionner parce qu'il y a tellement de
déclinaisons que c'est un petit peu
compliqué donc on va essayer de
comprendre ce qui a fait Google avec son
pixel 7a on va essayer de voir quelles
sont ses qualités quels sont ces défauts
à qui j'estime est-ce qu'il est fait
pour vous vous allez voir parce que il y
a vraiment beaucoup de choses à raconter
dessus allez c'est parti on y va
la première chose qu'on regarde un petit
peu ce qu'il y a dans la boîte parce que
vous allez voir c'est assez sommaire de
plus en plus de marques retire ici et
bien les blocs de charge et Google a
fait exactement la même chose donc vous
allez avoir des petits accessoires ça
c'est un petit accessoire pour mettre de
l'usba vers de l'usb-c c'est un petit
convertisseur ok vous allez avoir votre
câble de recharge en USB C USB C vous
allez avoir votre petit Picot pour venir
ouvrir le tiroir de carte SIM d'ailleurs
on va tout de suite regarder je vais
vous montrer vous allez voir hop tiroir
de carte SIM avec une seule SIM une
seule SIM 5G bien évidemment pas de
double sim pas la possibilité de venir
rajouter une extension de stockage d'un
côté ça c'est pas surprenant parce que
Google vous le savez et bien ils vont
vous proposer tous les services de
stockage dans le Cloud forcément ils ont
des services ils les vendent que ce soit
au niveau de la photo et au niveau de
plein de choses donc voilà donc ça
effectivement donc pas d'extension de
mémoire ici et puis ensuite c'est tout
c'est à dire pas de bloc de charge rien
donc Google vous fait du Google vous
propose du Google c'est vide c'est
simple c'est ça marche bien bon voilà
c'est efficace en tout cas c'est une
petite boîte qui est fort sympathique
alors on parle à la boîte on la dégage
moi je regarde le smartphone parce que
ce smartphone qui raconte plein de
choses la première chose alors j'ai mis
le déverrouillage avec la caméra vous
avez un capteur d'empreinte digitale qui
est bien positionné donc vous le prenez
en main vous posez votre doigt ça
déverrouille c'est bien c'est rapide
c'est très très bien la première chose
qu'on va venir regarder ici et ça c'est
intéressant c'est le contour le contour
au niveau des bordures que vous avez ici
des bordures noires c'est le premier
truc qui m'a un peu frappé à l'oeil
parce que de plus en plus de marche
cherche à faire des contours un peu plus
borderless c'est-à-dire on vient au
maximum sur le côté certains vont même
jusqu'à l'incurer sur le côté et
d'autres jusqu'à l'incurvé sur les
quatre côtés c'est notamment ce que nous
a fait Honor avec son Magic 5 Pro ici
par contre et bien on n'est pas dans la
même gamme donc on va pas tout mettre en
face mais pour autant Google s'est dit
on s'en fout on va garder des grandes
bordures et ça ça me plaît pas
énormément parce que les bordures ont
les veux pas on en veut de moins en
moins et voyez pour autant vous avez des
grandes bordures là sur le côté surtout
sur le côté et vous avez un grand menton
et personnellement je suis pas
extrêmement fan et j'aime pas trop je
trouve que c'est dommage et qu'en fait
c'est con parce que ce smartphone il est
bien il est assez compact il est pas
trop lourd il fait moins de 200 g il est
à 193 g donc voyez en terme de prise en
main on a un truc qui qui est bien qui
est convenable qui est cool mais pour
autant j'aime pas trop ce design que je
trouve un petit peu obsolète obsolète au
niveau du contour noir qu'on a donc ça
ça chiffonne un peu après je vous le dis
la prise en main est bonne le format est
très cool vous le bougez très facilement
le prof facilement en main il glisse pas
trop bon bref ça reste un très très bon
smartphone là-dessus qui est proposé
avec de l'aluminium recyclé donc ça
c'est bien on a également du plastique
et on va retrouver du vert vous avez du
Fashion lock il est verrouille
rapidement et ça c'est très pratique
donc capture d'empreinte digitale le
schéma l'école le fait son lock bref il
faut faire pas mal de choses maintenant
le truc me surprend ici c'est que Google
a fait le choix de vous mettre un
Corning Gorilla glace 3 c'est très vieux
aujourd'hui on met souvent encore une
Gorillaz 5 sur le milieu de gamme ici
ils ont mis encore une Doria glace 3
c'est une vieille techno de Corning
alors bon ça protège quand même
attention c'est mieux que rien mais je
trouve ça surprenant alors après autre
petite particularité c'est un smartphone
qui est quand même résistant à l'eau et
à la poussière avec une certification
IP67 on n'a pas de Lippé 68 comme sur
les pixel 7 et Pixel 7 Pro on a quand
même une protection une certification en
tout cas donc il est certifié résistant
à l'eau et à la poussière donc aussi
bien alors je voudrais qu'on parle
justement de cet écran parce que cet
écran il est pas mal il est intéressant
il est plutôt joli on a une grande dalle
de 6,1 pouces on a 0,2 pouces en dessous
du pixel 7 qui était à 6 bien qui est
d'ailleurs toujours à 6,3 pouces la
résolution c'est du Full HD plus ça me
paraît normal et on est sur une dalle
aux LED ça c'est bien qui Google nous
annonce 25 % plus lumineuse que ce qu'on
avait avant donc ça ça me plaît plutôt
pas mal c'est cool je vais avoir là je
suis à 64 % donc luminosité adaptatif ça
c'est pareil c'est un truc que je vous
recommande de venir mettre ici parce
qu'il veut dire s'adapter à l'éclairage
environnant la voyez c'est assez sombre
si je me dehors il y a beaucoup de
lumière donc fatalement il va falloir
jouer il va le faire automatiquement ce
thème sombre ok on peut mettre un thème
clair si on le souhaite j'aime bien le
thème song je trouve assez efficace ici
les couleurs adaptative alors vous avez
soit de l'adaptatif soit du naturel
c'est à vous de voir je l'ai mis sur
adaptatif je trouve un peu plus saturé
un peu plus pêchu donc ça va bien ce
sont par défaut il est comme ça et après
il y a plein de petits paramètres alors
vous le voyez il y a un truc intéressant
qui est juste ici affichage fluide
augmenter automatiquement la fréquence
d'actualisation de 60 à 90 Hertz pour
certains contenus la batterie est
davantage sollicité alors
je trouve ça bien effectivement plein de
marques le propose par contre c'est
pareil c'est un truc que je trouve un
peu dommage et un peu daté c'est-à-dire
que plein de marques même des
smartphones qui seront moins chers et je
vous donne le tarif dans quelques
instants propose un taux de
rafraîchissement qui va jusqu'à 120
Hertz c'est la norme aujourd'hui
pourquoi est-ce que Google ici nous a
mis uniquement un taux de
rafraîchissement maximal de 90 Hz c'est
ça un choix qui est assez surprenant non
pas que ce soit vraiment décolon d'un
point de vue purement technologique mais
par rapport au marché par rapport à ce
que propose les concurrents 90 ça peut
être un peu déceptif et certains diront
bon bah moi je vais parler là-dessus je
vais plutôt aller sur un autre
smartphone qui lui sera beaucoup plus
élevé en nombre d'images par seconde que
ce que je vais avoir là donc voyez bon
c'est pas non plus ouf après il y a un
autre truc que je trouve pas ouf ouf et
qui m'a un peu déçu c'est l'expérience
audio alors en fait regardez je vais
vous faire écouter vous allez mieux
comprendre vous avez deux haut-parleurs
le premier haut-parleur il va s'y de
tuer par ici c'est le parleur principal
et deuxième haut-parleurs il est situé
là c'est le haut-parleur que vous
utilisez pour passer un coup de fil et
le mettre en mode haut-parleur lorsque
vous passez un coup de fil donc on aura
un son un peu plus médium et donc
là-dessus il y a rien de surprenant
c'est un choix qu'il faut beaucoup font
sauf qu'ici le son est quand même
vachement médium et je trouve ça un peu
dommage je le mets à fond vous êtes on
écoute
là c'est très étouffé c'est dommage
alors celui-là là à droite il est pas
mal lui là franchement il envoie du bois
mais lui bon et yes déséquilibre et
c'est vrai que je l'entends alors il y a
plein de smartphone ou fatalement je
vais l'entendre pour l'instant c'est un
rangement grand placard c'est très
pratique et moi j'ai pas besoin de ça
pas besoin de tous ces placards là donc
bon après il me direz-vous est-ce bien
grave dans l'absolu non mais bon il faut
essayer de venir un peu pour des raisons
tout ça alors après rassurez-vous vous
allez pouvoir me dire mettre des
écouteurs sans fil Bluetooth grâce au
Bluetooth 5.3 donc là ça fonctionne
c'est très actuel c'est un petit peu un
petit bémol après une fois de plus très
honnêtement il est dans la course et
c'est pas là-dessus je vais venir
disqualifier donc pour moi ça reste un
smartphone qui fonctionne là dessus ok
aucun problème mais que serait Google
sur Google sans faire du Google et c'est
ce que Google vient vous proposer ici à
savoir que c'est une expérience qui
cherche en tout cas est vraiment
différente de ce qu'on va venir
retrouver ailleurs et pour le coup il le
sait pourquoi parce qu'en fait Google
ils vont utiliser leur smartphone pour
valoriser tous les services que Google
propose à commencer par Google Agenda
vous voyez là je dois 40 € Arthur donc
dans 16 minutes ça t'envoie quelques
jours plus mais je dois donner de
l'argent à Arthur bonjour Arthur
d'ailleurs si tu regardes cette vidéo
j'ai la météo j'ai plein de widgets que
je peux ajouter et personnalisé
exactement la même chose que j'ai sur
les autres Google les autres pixels
pixel 7 pixel 7 pro c'est la même idée
donc c'est vous proposer tous les
services personnalisés de Google ici et
ça ils savent faire et ils le font très
bien pourquoi parce que déjà alors vous
êtes sur la dernière version d'Android
ici c'est Android 13 on s'en doutera
donc une fois de plus Android 13 c'est
bien ça marche bien c'est efficace ça me
plaît bien mais vous allez avoir
également ce que Google appellera les
futurs drop et les futurs drop c'est
quoi alors le nom est un peu voilà on
n'est pas en anglophone fatalement c'est
un peu plus complexe les futurs drop
c'est quoi c'est en fait Google qui va
venir vous pousser des mises à jour
régulièrement et qui vous enverra de
nouvelles fonctionnalités tous les trois
mois sans même que vous le sachiez et ça
c'est cool pourquoi parce que ça rend
votre smartphone plus intelligent et
plus malin dès Google à développer une
fonctionnalité qui est compatible dans
votre langue elle est poussée sur votre
smartphone enfin elle fait partie du
paquet de mise à jour qui arrivera tous
les trois mois après le truc qui est des
fois un peu relou c'est que Google ne
communique pas dessus donc vous le savez
pas mais tiens un jour ah mais c'est
nouveau ça je savais pas il y a une
nouvelle fonctionnalité et en fait ce
qui est cool c'est que c'est un
smartphone qui est vraiment évolutif et
c'est vraiment pour moi le gros point
fort de ce smartphone c'est qu'il est
pas figé un instant T où vous allez
venir l'acheter bien évidemment Google
c'est avant tout du logiciel au collier
Google le moteur de recherche tous les
services qui viennent proposer derrière
bien évidemment mais c'est surtout
vraiment ce logiciel qui est mis en
avant et sur lequel Google
travaille énormément donc vous avez
plein de fonctionnalités qui sont hyper
cool donc quand vous venez dans vos
paramètres vous allez voir vous pouvez
par exemple aller dans son et vibreur
vous allez pouvoir descendre dans clarté
d'appel et venir activer la clarté
d'appel alors la clarté d'appel c'est
quoi c'est quand vous êtes dans un
environnement qui est extrêmement
bruyant et bien il y a tout un travail
algorithmique qui va se faire grâce aux
différents micros pour venir annuler le
son environnant bruyant et faire un
focus uniquement sur votre voix pour que
votre interlocuteur vous entende très
bien et des fonctionnalités comme ça il
y en a des tonnes vous avez une
fonctionnalité par exemple quand vous
recevez un SMS et bien va pouvoir venir
vous lire votre SMS ça c'est vachement
bien pour les personnes qui ont des
déficiences visuelles vous allez avoir
aussi un assistant pour vos appels le
col assiste la traduction en temps réel
lorsque vous voyagez c'est vraiment
génial il va venir traduire directement
la dictée de SMS également vous dicter
tac tac lui tape vous embêtez pas et il
y a plein de super fonctionnalités qui
sont là également pour toutes vos photos
à savoir par exemple bien la gomme
magique alors je viens dans Google
photos je clique sur Modifier gomme
magique donc lui il est en train de
regarder pour me proposer des
suggestions qu'est-ce que je peux venir
virer sur ma photo alors ça dépend si
c'est des fois un peu compliqué il va
pas y arriver donc là hop là il cherche
il cherche il cherche les petites
suggestions la voyez il y a tous ces
gens là à venir virer alors moi je lui
marque tout effacer on va voir comment
il gère ça et voyez j'ai une rue qui est
quand même beaucoup plus propre alors il
a eu un petit peu de mal ici là vous
voyez mais si je reviens en arrière tous
ces gens là sont là ils ont disparu ça
me clean massel et ça je trouve ça une
fois de plus extrêmement bluffant bon je
vais le laisser parce que hop là j'en ai
besoin pour plus tard donc vous avez
cette fameuse gomme magique là par
exemple j'ai une photo si vous la
trouvez un petit peu floue c'est pareil
vous allez dans modifier vous venez dans
vos paramètres vous allez dans Outils et
vous allez avoir par exemple anti-flou
donc lui il va venir travailler pour
rendre votre photo moins flou alors bon
c'est pas la photo la plus floue du
monde donc c'est pas forcément ce qui a
bien beau parler mais si vous avez par
exemple une vieille photo que vous avez
pris j'en sais rien moi une photo de
votre mémé de votre pépé qui est un peu
flou et bien vous la passez là-dedans ça
vous l'aurore beaucoup plus d’être et je
vous l'avais déjà montré avec le pixel
pro il y a un côté un peu perturbant
parce que j'ai l'impression qu'elle
revie et ça c'est quand même un peu
bizarre mais pour autant c'est cool
alors il y a plein de choses au niveau
de la photo de la vidéo et je vous en
parle un peu plus tard mais voyez il y a
toutes ces fonctionnalités qu'on a ici
avec Google on peut utiliser son
smartphone pour déverrouiller sa bagnole
on peut en faire énormément chose vous
avez fait un live l'année dernière pour
vous présenter plein de figures d'Europe
allez jeter un coup d'oeil c'était sur
le pixel 6a mais ça reste très actuel il
y a plein de nouvelles fonctionnalités
qui sont arrivées donc si vous aimez
vraiment l'expérience logiciel vous
voulez voir de nouveautés savoir ce que
vous propose votre pixel et bien sachez
qu'ici vous allez avoir des mises à jour
régulières qui vont arriver et ça c'est
un très gros point fort de ce smartphone
et tout ça comment est-ce que il a fait
Google parce qu'effectivement et bien
Google ils ont dû venir travailler
différemment avant Google intégrer dans
ces smartphones des processeurs de
Qualcomm des Snapdragon ça dépend des
bien évidemment du smartphone mais
depuis le pixel 6 et bien je vous l'ai
dit ils ont mis leur puce maison la puce
tensor est arrivé la G1 sur le pixel 6
et avec le pixel 7 est arrivé là G2 g
pour Google donc on a cette nouvelle
puce qui est arrivé et cette nouvelle
puce elle sert à quoi et bien elle est
optimisée pour tout ce que Google va
chercher à faire c'est-à-dire vous
délivrer des services d'excellente
qualité sur le traitement la photo la
vidéo bref surtout ce dont vous avez
besoin pour ce produit signé Google
alors soyons clairs attention ça je vous
l'ai déjà dit c'est pas la puce vous
allez avoir le plus de performances non
c'est pas le cas donc vous allez pas
avoir une puce avec énormément vraiment
de performance si vous venez faire un
benchmark sur autotou vous serez
largement en dessous de ce que vous
propose Qualcomm même médiathèque sauf
que ici la réalité c'est que Google il
s'en foutent un peu d'être en haut du
classement d'un an toutou par exemple
eux ce qu'ils veulent c'est que ça
marche vraiment bien avec tout ce que
vous allez avoir à l'intérieur et ici
c'est le cas donc cette puce elle est
dédiée totalement à ce smartphone et en
plus de ça Google s'est dit ok avoir une
puce qui marche bien c'est cool mais on
veut aussi rajouter une grosse couche de
sécurité et là ils ont sorti
effectivement alors c'est la nouvelle
version mais la puce Titan m2 c'est
exactement le même niveau de performance
et le même niveau de sécurité que vous
avez sur les smartphones les plus haut
de gamme chez Google pixel 7 Pro donc ça
c'est cool alors après ce qu'on pourrait
venir reprocher c'est que ici on a que 8
Go de RAM alors qu'on pourrait vouloir
avoir et bien un peu plus un petit 12
non on a du 8 Go de RAM et on a un
stockage unique en 128 Go de stockage
alors je suis en 128 mais vous marque
pas ici la RAM mais c'est du 8 Go et
pour Google c'est suffisant par rapport
à ce qu'ils ont à vous proposer ici
alors soyons clairs c'est pas le
smartphone qui va être dédié pour la
performance brute pour la grosse
expérience de gaming à ce moment là
mieux vaut aller sur un smartphone qui
vous proposera reste la dragonne 8 GN2
mais bon si vous voulez faire tourner
plein de jeux du Play Store avec ce
smartphone vous n'aurez absolument aucun
problème ça tournera ça ira très bien
donc bon voyage soyez quand même
vachement assuré et Google a voulu aller
plus loin en termes de sécurité on vous
proposant notamment bien le fait d'avoir
un VPN avec Google one donc si vous
voulez avoir votre VPN et vous voulez
tranquille pour sécuriser vos connexions
Internet et bien vous en avez un
directement ici maison et ça c'est pas
mal non plus maintenant il y a un autre
point à venir voir c'est toute la partie
de l'autonomie l'autonomie ça jamais été
le gros point fort chez Google et ce
pixel 7a c'est un peu la même histoire
alors soyons clairs Google est très
honnête ils vous disent pas vous avez
toujours d'autonomie ils vous disent
vous avez 24 heures d'autonomie donc
attendez vous à garder une bonne journée
et à venir le recharger ok sauf que il
vous disent vous avez un mode qui vous
permettra de pousser beaucoup plus loin
si vous avez vraiment besoin avec un une
demi heure de batterie vous pouvez venir
activer l'économiseur de batterie et
avec même l'ultra économiseur de
batterie vous pouvez venir choisir de
mettre vous choisissez les applications
que vous allez utiliser les applications
essentielles et c'est tout voyez vous
venez de choisir vous directement donc
ça va vachement brider votre téléphone
et vous n'aurez pas accès à 100 % des
capacités de votre téléphone mais ça
vous permettra d'aller jusqu'à 72 heures
d'autonomie bon jusqu'à attention c'est
l'extrémité après il faut savoir qu'ici
vous avez pas une très grosse batterie
quand même vous avez une batterie de
4385 millions par heure est-ce qu'on
peut venir regretter c'est que la charge
est pas extrêmement rapide vous annonce
une charge rapide 18 Watts c'est pas fou
fou par rapport à ce qu'on retrouve sur
le marché aujourd'hui dans cette gamme
de tarifs et j'y viens dans quelques
instants on s'attend à avoir des charges
un peu plus rapides que du 18 Watts
surtout que là on parle de 18 Watts de
filières mais si vous allez en sans fil
vous arrivez à 7,5 watts et ça c'est
pareil pour moi il se qualifie pas et
c'est pas bon et c'est dommage on aurait
au moins 25 watts on dirait bon ok c'est
pas trop trop dégueu et de la charge
sans fil 15 watts c'est pas le cas ici
c'est divisé par deux donc voyez c'est
tous ces petits trucs qui font que
aujourd'hui bon en fait et vous allez
voir que petit à petit on y arrive c'est
que ce smartphone il est destiné aux
personnes qui veulent du Google qui
aiment Google qui veulent un pixel qui
veulent un excellent pixel et qui
veulent pas se prendre la tête tout ça
un tarif extrêmement maîtrisé mais qui
s'en foutent de ce petit contour noir
qui sont fous de l'avoir de la recharge
très rapide et qui veulent juste une
excellente expérience Google un tarif un
peu plus maîtrisé et puisqu'on parle de
Google et l'expérience Google Google ils
sont très forts dans un truc c'est quoi
c'est la photographie ils sont très fort
dans la photographie computationnel et
la photographie computationnelle c'est
quoi et bien c'est toute l'IA que vous
allez avoir derrière en fait vous avez
le smartphone qui va venir prendre sa
photo et on va être traité par des
algorithmes d'arrière pour la maximiser
et vous donner la meilleure photo
possible Google pendant des années a mis
un seul capteur sur ces appareils photos
en faisant ça sert à rien on sait faire
très bien avec un seul capteur bon ils
sont dit on va changer un peu l'histoire
et on va sur les pixels 7 Pro vous
regardez vous avez trois capteurs grand
temps ultra grand temps de téléobjectif
là sur le 7 a ils y sont allés un peu
plus Molos ce qui n'est pas déconnant
par rapport à ce qu'on trouve sur le
marché donc ça me surprend pas vous avez
votre grand-angle et vous avez un ultra
grand-angle pas de téléobjectif ça c'est
ce que propose également beaucoup de
constructeurs donc c'est pas déconnant
vous allez avoir un grand angle de 64
mégapixels et un ultra grand angle de 13
mégapixels sans oublier une caméra de
selfie à l'avant qu'on vient retrouver
juste ici qu'elle est également une 13
mégapixels bon je vous montre le
résultat quelques instants par contre le
truc qui est intéressant ici c'est que
lorsque vous voulez me dire faire de la
vidéo et bien on peut venir faire de la
vidéo surtout les capteurs directement
en 4K à 30 images par seconde alors on
peut monter sur le grand angle jusqu'à
60 images par seconde ça c'est possible
mais par contre sur l'ultra grand-angle
et sur la caméra de ces filles vous
pouvez filmer jusqu'en 4K à 30 images
par seconde donc ici vous attendez pas
avoir de téléobjectif il va falloir vous
contenter d'abord un zoom numérique qui
ira jusqu'au x 8 et uniquement jusqu'en
x 8 comme ça ça évitera aussi de venir
dégrader la qualité de la photo qui dit
pixel des photos des belles photos on va
regarder effectivement si ce pixel 7a et
comme les autres fait vraiment de très
très jolies photos alors déjà regardez
photos prises au grand angle à ultra
grand-angle moi je trouve ça vraiment
efficace ça marche bien que au niveau du
ciel ici et ça c'est très très beau on
continue ici une petite balade dans
Clermont-Ferrand c'est vraiment très
très bien maîtrisé très joli lumière sur
la cathédrale l'ultra grand-angle va
bien on aura un peu en précision sur les
côtés mais ça c'est normal il y a rien
qui est de bien déconner ici alors on va
pas venir trop zoomer on va venir zoomer
un tout petit peu mais pas trop parce
que on est que sur du numérique et voyez
ça ne va pas du tout ce qu'on fait 8
c'est pas terrible alors on peut pas
faire de macro sur ce smartphone Google
est vraiment allé à l'essentiel et c'est
ça qui me plaît énormément c'est à dire
que vous avez uniquement deux capteurs
et ces deux capteurs vont faire le job
donc ici on met pas de macro ici on met
pas de téléobjectif ici on va pas mettre
plein de capteurs pour mettre des
capteurs on met que ce qui marche
qu'est-ce qu'on attend et ça c'est
vraiment bien donc on va se dire
effectivement ça smartphone avec deux
capteurs là où vous en avez plein moins
cher avec trois capteurs mais qui ne
servent vraiment à rien donc ce qu'on a
ici certes on peut venir faire un X2
numérique sur de la nourriture pour
obtenir un côté un peu macro vite fait
les histoires de se marrer mais c'est
pas mal franchement le résultat est
quand même correct vous voyez c'était
bon c'est pas que là je me suis fait
plaisir sur des petites fleurs on va pas
trop aller loin mais on peut bien faire
des choses se rapprocher un peu c'est
très très cool vous voyez je vous
montrer rapidement c'est beau hein c'est
on est au bord de la mer regardez le
rendu les couleurs sont très naturelles
je trouve ça vraiment bien et très très
jolie de good Google regardez ça là sur
le grand angle c'est magnifique l'ultra
grand-angle et aussi super joli j'aime
bien ce que c'est pas sur saturé si vous
regardez au fond vous voyez vous avez
pas l'espèce de verre sur saturé le bleu
est très naturel donc tout reste très
doux et très naturel en plus les
capteurs entre le grand angle et l'ultra
grand angle sont les mêmes donc c'est
très maîtrisé c'est très rare ça donc ça
c'est vachement bien ce qu'a fait Google
ici dans sa chambre effectivement la
force de Google c'est la photographie
computationnelle c'est l'ordinateur en
arrière qui bosse et on a une vraie
cohérence entre le grand angle ultra
grand-angle c'est beau c'est maîtrisé
donc là c'est pour moi un très gros oui
très très gros oui je vous le montre on
zoom ça sert strictement à rien et vous
allez vagaler plein de photos dans
l'ensemble on va avancer vous allez voir
que c'est vraiment super joli alors
c'est déformant attention ultra
grand-angle il faut pas le shooter
n'importe comment mais par contre je
trouve ça vraiment très très beau dans
un sens dans l'autre voilà donc vraiment
très très joli travail qui a été fait
ici il y a de la part de Google avec le
soleil en face vous voyez aucun problème
et globalement j'adore vraiment le rendu
photo qu'on a ici qui est neutre coucou
avec mon Elliott qui est beau vous voyez
avec le contre jour là j'ai bien la
lumière là rien n'est cramé tout est
maîtrisé tout est juste tout est bien
balancé bien exposé j'adore on peut
s'amuser à faire de la création vous
voyez dans l'espace de petits trous en
haut là on va faire des petites créa je
vais me marrer ouais non non vraiment
très très bien donc la photo du genre
c'est pas moi qui l'ai mis au sol papier
GRUY était déjà là vous voyez voilà donc
moi c'est un très très gros oui ici
regardez ça comme c'est magnifique ça ça
Marseille très très très gros oui on a
fait un gros shooting à Marseille et
vous en ai plein de jolies photos donc
pour moi c'est vachement bien et c'est
vraiment très gros ici bon alors la
caméra de selfie fatalement c'est moins
bien on s'en doutera je trouve que bah
vous voyez on est avec des collègues là
on bouge un petit peu très légèrement et
c'est tout de suite pas terrible alors
il y a un truc qui est intéressant ce
qu'on nous a fait Google c'est que vous
avez en fait un espèce d'ultra grand
angle lorsque vous êtes vous voyez ça
c'est fait d'ultra grand angle et là on
vient se rapprocher un petit peu moi je
trouve quand il y a pas beaucoup de
lumière on a beaucoup de mal quand il y
a de la lumière ça donne un résultat qui
est pas mauvais une fois de plus merci
la photographie computationnelle
là-dessus c'est pas dégueu mais je
trouve pas ça fou fou quand vous avez
plein de soleil ça marche bien c'est
sympa mais au-delà de ça vous voyez ça
typiquement et bien les visages on a
l'impression que ça bouge un peu c'est
pas terrible donc ça c'est quand même un
peu un peu moyen je vous montre deux
trois photos en mode portrait sur notre
portrait il est pas mal une fois de plus
on le voit lorsque vous venez de prendre
la photo la photo elle est normale et
puis ensuite on voit l'algo qui PAF vous
créez le flou qui est complètement
artificiel ici avec quelques ratés très
légers la voyez au niveau des cheveux là
il a eu légèrement du mal mais vraiment
léger une fois de plus et il y a qui va
venir reconnaître mais dans l'ensemble
c'est quand même plutôt pas mal fichu
ici là hop là si vous regardez ici c'est
pareil avec mon petit Steven bah
globalement il bosse quand même très
très bien même s'il y a deux trois
petits détails ou des fois il va avoir
un petit peu de mal oui il y a
typiquement là sur la veste là là si
vous venez regarder là et ben il m'a
bouffer un petit bout de la veste mais
il l'a confondu avec la moquette d'un
autre côté c'est Steven qui comme ça
donc c'est pas déconnant je t'embrasse
là vous regardez ici pareil sur Anne
globalement le boulot est bien fait ça
marche bien donc là dessus bravo Google
je suis ton regard aussi un petit peu la
photo de nu parce que c'est vraiment un
point très important ici donc
différentes scènes là j'ai eu un petit
peu de mal avec la lumière à côté qui
m'a créé cette espèce d'artefact qui
sont pas terrible pour autant bon
globalement le rendu est pas mauvais là
il a eu un peu de mal au niveau de
lumière là où d'autres smartphones plus
haut de gamme auront un peu moins de mal
bon une fois de plus on est dans le
milieu de gamme on est à 500 balles donc
bon ça me surprend pas et ça marche bien
alors vous voyez il y a une petite
différence là de colorimétrie la
regarder voyez pareil la lumière il a eu
un petit peu de mal ici vu que sur le
grand angle là je voulais pas l'ultra
grand-angle parce que c'est pas fait
pour la photo de nuit mais voyez là il a
un petit peu de mal par endroit donc là
c'est un peu la limite du truc qu'on va
venir retrouver ici l'appareil voyez les
lumières il a du mal voilà là
effectivement c'est la différence qu'on
a avec les autres modèles le pixel 7 pro
et le pixel 7 bien qu'on ait le même le
même processeur ici vous voyez là les
lumières hop hop les feux ici là il en
veut pas il a du mal bon c'est de vous
faire des photos comme ça mais par
contre globalement c'est pas mal c'est
pas mal fichu ça ça dépend ça c'est naze
complet vous voyez là une fois de plus
de lumière des soucoupes volantes dans
le donc si vous voyez des ovnis en photo
ça vient de votre smartphone c'est pas
des OVNI soyons clairs là à Munich
globalement le rendu est pas mal alors
en ville c'est plus maîtrisé que lorsque
vous avez vraiment de la nuit peut-être
parce que vous avez plus de lumière donc
c'est un peu mieux pour lui mais une
fois de plus vous voyez un petit peu
cramé ici sinon bon dans l'ensemble les
photos nues sont sympas c'est une photo
prise avec la caméra arrière ça vient
lisser un petit peu le visage là je
trouve ça pas foufou mais sinon on
arrive quand même à sortir des choses
qui sont qui sont globalement pas
mauvaises regardez même là dans un taxi
avec Sofiane je trouve que c'est pas mal
ce petit jeu de lumière donc on a quand
même un smartphone qui est magnifique en
photo de jour là vraiment il y a rien à
dire la nuit il est un petit peu en
dessous mais il coûte 500 balles on
comprendra la caméra de selfie elle est
moyenne aussi mais une fois de plus il
coûte 500 balles donc pour moi en terme
de promesses et de rendre une photo dans
cette gamme de tarif c'est un oui un
grand oui donc ça smartphone qui a
toutes les technos on a bien évidemment
du wifi 6e on a bien évidemment de la 5G
il est très actuel il est donc
performant il a les dernières techno il
est certifié il est bien alors pour moi
il y a quelques petits points vous voyez
quelque chose qui a fait Google qui sont
quand même surprenants mais ça reste un
bon smartphone qu'il est performant dans
l'univers Google donc si vous recherchez
un smartphone 100% Google dans l'univers
Google avec toute l'expérience Google et
toutes ces nouveautés ces mises à jour
qui sont poussées régulièrement le pixel
7a est très cool et vous pouvez y aller
sans aucun problème c'est un excellent
smartphone alors le tarif parlons-en il
est là regardez je m'affiche le tarif
alors il est proposé au tarif de 5009 €
ça c'est quand même qui est très
maîtrisé alors 509 € c'est intéressant
parce que il faut mettre ça un peu en
perspective si vous regardez le pixel 7
il est proposé à 649 €. donc 150 balles
en gros de plus ce qui est quand même
une certaine somme soyons clair mais
j'ai trouvé le pixel 7 sur une
Marketplace en 9 à 520 euros donc en
fait c'est quasiment le même tarif donc
la question aujourd'hui à se poser c'est
est-ce que je vais acheter mon pixel 7a
directement dans le commerce sur tous
les vendeurs que je connais ou ça me
rassure où j'ai tout laissé ça ou alors
est-ce que je peux aller voir sur une
Marketplace et trouver mon pixel 7 pour
beaucoup moins cher c'est une vraie
question alors attention une fois de
plus regardez où est l'acheteur est-ce
qu'il est en France est-ce qu'il est en
Europe quels sont les garanties quels
sont les notes faites attention lorsque
vous achetez sur une Marketplace même si
c'est sur des Marketplace sérieux ce ne
sont pas eux qui vont gérer les GA
[Musique]